just kidding news careful boys is a
brand just kidding news is the man of
smart people the people of just kidding
news careful boys they are very smart
just kidding news the number one podcast
in the
[Music]
world welcome back to another exciting
episode of the careful boys where hey we
got silent Mike back here y'all wo you
this for every guest no yeah lately it's
a new thing
clap I know but like I want to be
special like either want to be so
careful boy you don't clap for me or I
want to be the guy you [__] clap
you're special because you're here yeah
I do feel special cuz we could stop
clapping because then I'm the guy you
don't clap for and then you clap for for
every [__] there's a little
snowflake in well we did give you a a
careful Boy shirt but you're not even
wearing it I'm going to put it on how
many episodes we got you know I got to
sell these shirts you know you know hit
them B what's that promo my brand good
company you know you can't promote your
brand here you asked you asked canot you
asked W wo set I know so like I just
answered I didn't try it again Joe try
it again what's that carful boo.com
that's tight wait I don't think we own
that strike to all right just just Baro
brigade.com no just go in the
description there's a careful boys link
right there thanks Bart okay here's a
fun
question what historical figure would
you most like to sit and have a
conversation with over tea over tea tea
over tea I'm drinking coffee [__] fine
that's fine don't call me a [__] sorry
that was just to the conversation
nobody's clapping for you for the rest
of the [__] video Little Wayne Little
Wayne says I'm drinking hot tea [__]
that's why it sticks in my head okay
sure whatever what kind of like Little
Wayne you like jasmine tea I don't like
any tea you don't spill the tea I like
that tea I do like a little drama I do
like a little drama how can you not like
te there's so many variations a lot of
stuff it's like so many kinds I'm pretty
like neutral on things it's not like a
dislike but I'm never going to order do
you like roasted flavors
n what about mushroom tea you like
coffee I love coffee like Bean Tea
mushroom tea legum tea yeah no I'm out
I'm scared similar what kind of notes in
your coffee do you like I like a really
blonde roast high caffeine we still
talking about coffee yeah coffee oh okay
I don't know who I'm inviting mohamm oi
probably you probably need some high
mountain tea I think you'll like it from
Taiwan I'd pick Jon and VAR so that I
could see if she was Hot or Not y see if
she could fight you know they said
Cleopatra was like one of the hottest
chicks ever ever I want to see if she's
hot you think ugly chick's going to be
like move her ranks up during that time
that's true there's that one Turkish
lady that's going around that looks like
Asma borat's best friend and then
they're like she was once the most
beautiful woman all over oh yeah taste
might have changed but yeah taste
definitely changed cuz didn't they like
prioritize a woman that could like for
example whoop the [__] out of everybody
so round Rousey your favorite yeah I do
like a little you literally look 20
years years ago and we're talking we're
talking no cakes skinny ass legs and now
we're in the area of the booty what
about the other UFC chick who like did
the Star Wars
show oh Gina corano Gina corano carano's
very she's like the bad actually started
she's actually I think H you know where
she actually started with Jen on
American Gladiator she was on American
Gladiator but before that she was
already kickboxing star did she get
kicked off of the Star Wars stuff I
think so but like what did she do beat
up like a Ewok I don't know oh yeah the
Star Wars is new new no no it was
political Tweet stuff I think like some
R party stuff trumping no I don't Trum
Trump trump or something antivaccine
stuff it might have been vaccine Ain
that crazy y you can't have opinion and
have a job she was a big part of that
show yeah if you have the wrong opinion
I don't think you should have a certain
all right I agree maybe you don't even
have life at that point pay I'd pay the
price at that level though you know if
you get to a certain level and there's
certain rules as long as you knew what
the rules were so you want to be like
you rather be like John
Cena yeah exactly yeah because China
let's go yep you know what I'm saying
apologize in Chinese which was sick yeah
The Rock will do it too because they got
so many [__] sales in China that' be
making up over like 30% of the revenue
i' rather be middle class and have my
freedom you are
that yeah that's
true genas Khan all of with that
[__] yeah but what if he you
what if but why do you want to have tea
with them just probably cuz like that
he's done like the most powerful crazy
man [__] ever yeah for real like who
else has done [__] like him he's done
some crazy [__] him yeah my real is
probably Muhammad Ali just cuz he's so
funny Mak me giggle who built the Great
Wall of China who was like the the guy
who came up with it I think it survived
like two Emperors or some [__] who's the
emperor who's like started my idea but
he didn't even get to see it finish yeah
but like who's like the SAT Legend
satosi Nakamoto he's like uh
I think he was the guy that unified
China that's how you know the pyramids
were fake though right cuz like the
Great Wall of China took like 8,000
years to build and pyramids are like oh
it took 50 years the first emperor i q
was that give it to me I would meet with
him you and I would clown on him the
whole time about nobody gives a [__]
about the Great Wall anymore dude and
everyone just they they take pictures of
it now rocks from wall not even that
good of a defense playground [__] but
then is he going to be like but did it
work did it keep the Mongolians out be
like it didn't even do the job they
wanted to cuz the Mongolians went around
the wall fol yeahum
[__] Trump and then I'd say Trump Trump
trump for the next 10 minutes at dinner
or at tea isn't Biden actually helping
to complete the wall I think yesterday
man the Wall's going up yeah I think I
might try to meet with my great grandpa
or something just to understand my
history I didn't want to go sad how is
that sad I say my dad but that's like
sad that's that sad
and then let's take it sad because
that's interesting yeah well for me I
think would be to learn or my grandpa
cuz I think when he was around I was so
his out of his kids my dad is the
youngest one so he has seven kids my
dad's the youngest one so when I was a
kid he was already like
809s so I didn't really get to spend
that much time with them and I think I'd
be able to learn just more about our
family history so his dad which is your
great grandpa is a old kung Fu Master
like 18 He he was a Trad Tradesman I've
seen pictures of him he has like a
[__] Monopoly top hat so they used to
trade herbs from China to Peru and so
like I want to like understand just all
that history like how was it like on
ships and [__] for months at a time
[__]
so do you know uh like what year your
grandpa was born my grandpa yeah oh dude
like [__] like 1907 or something my
grandpa's about that I think my
grandpa's 1912 was old dude I would meet
George Washington and I'd be like I live
way better than you did
dude president of the United States I
have an air conditioner look at my teeth
is real true refrigerator I got Ice Dude
you got donkey teeth my boy I live way
better than you [__] you know we
live better than [__] JP Morgan's old
ass and he's a million Rock the OG
Rockefeller [__] I'd meet with him too
and tell him how good my life is we all
in the future we all got personal
drivers it's called Uber in the future
you could have any world's Cuisine
delivered to your [__] door is it all
relative though like they don't know
that exists so they don't complain about
it no dude but then you rub it in the
face I rub it in his face Did You Know
The Peasants of our time we get every
cultural Cuisine we want we can get air
conditioning and on top of that the
hottest girls you could jack off to that
American peasants of our time on my
phone dude look at this I'm beating it
to this chick on my phone dude I can see
any Chick you name I can see her
butthole on my phone don't to leave my
house to cheat ain't that crazy though
back then you had to be a [__] King
to have a team of only fans girls and
even then would you have like a dozen
yeah they're probably missing Limbs and
[__] probably a bunch of uggos too you
know [__] dude I got to go through a
whole alphabetical list I know and
sometimes it takes like 22 pages to go
from A to B but the difference is they
were all reserved for the king like only
is more like ride share cuz you're just
all sharing but you don't really get to
touch them that's true you're sharing
with like thousand other dudes why just
be dunking on every [__] from
history who thought they were so tight
who's another one you would [__] dunk
on that you kind of have like beef with
a little bit AB Lincoln dude AB Lincoln
AB probably sucks though you think so
yeah I've heard that's an interesting T
yeah it probably sucks a Lincoln would
probably go to you and be like dude I
[__] love puss dude I [__] [__]
that's what I say I like did you know
everyone's calling you [__] gay yeah
how do you feel about that everyone
thinks you're gay a asking me if he
slays
vampires if he slays vampires yeah he's
a I don't need to ask him that CU I know
he does let's move on to a better
question
word but i' would be like hey Abe like
everyone's calling you gay it's so
[__] up dude or no or no you know what
I would do I'd be like hey AE um what's
your take on gay people and I record it
cuz every every everyone in the gay
community now is being is they they
always put this quote up that says like
whatever you are be a good one I
guarantee aink is walking around calling
people gay and saying like don't do gay
[__] [__] you allit guarantee a was like
the biggest gay hater of all time
especially if he was actually gay he was
definitely like outwardly projected is
there an AB Lincoln gay story going on
apparently he had like a lover or
something like that like a friend that
he would sleep that would like live with
him when did that stop being cool cuz
like Marcus aelius yeah Marcus Aurelius
is probably [__] little boys oh
thousand but it was probably cool
Italians and Greeks and Romans they were
[__] doing that I heard that
yeah like when you're in a I heard that
[__] all the time when you're like hey
I'm leonado Da Vinci and I'm a teen and
I want to learn how to paint and then
you're like well you got I'm going to
you got to suck this dick for payment
you never heard of that [__] no for sure
that's what I'm saying but it was cool
and normal when did it
stop I don't know if it stopped I just
think it's not cool and normal I think
when social media came out social media
you think if I maybe the 1800s if I were
have tea with Marcus Aurelius You' think
like we would have conversations about
stuff and the more conversations I ask
he would Tred to [__] me you think you
would try to think you look pretty yeah
he probably tried to [__] me I think who
kept it going was the
vaan the Vatican kept it going they're
traditionalists for
sure so your grandpa huh so what your
father tell us about your father well
just like my dad died when I was pretty
young not that young like 22 23 you get
why would you it no yeah like we were
really close but like why wouldn't I
want to hang out with him again cuz you
could sit down with Muhammad Ali yeah i'
if I had to choose to be my dad proba oh
okay what about Jonah to see if she's
hot okay Jonah VAR that my
dad you think she killed with looks see
if she was hot you think she's ugly you
think she's just
like who's the blonde one in Game of
Thrones the night girl Cersei oh no the
no the [__] Brianna tart she's like
right there right Bri the giant lady
Bri J like like a 5ot ver of her baby
you guys never seen her picture she's
showing her titties yeah she's kind of
hot she's leading the charge no Brian or
whatever about Jonah [__] or Brienne of
Arc there's a picture of Jonah Arc wa
Jon of Arc is show her titties while
fighting yes was that like a distraction
look at Jonah AR she's [__] half
naked titties hanging out J our titties
she holding a [__] flag and she's
leading the charge it's a painting it's
not a picture we don't know how hot she
was it also too it's like she's kind of
hot in some of these titty do you see
titties I don't see the titty ones cuz I
didn't type in titties
Peter Pan I think that's the
movie but it's also hard to decipher
those paintings because they're all
metaphorical I know like they'll have
like a Spartan with a [__] harp and
you know he didn't go to war with a harp
but that's supposed to mean this and
they'll just throw these things in
paintings I don't know what the hell
that means so her showing her paint
titties I don't know what that means hey
forget J Arc I want to beat Mulan dude
that's who I want to have dinner is
Mulan even real she's a real person
she's she's a real is she real yeah she
had that little dragon buddy was talking
Eddie Murphy yeah I know Eddie M sound
like the clumps I know Eddie why norid
in
there let me see I'm going Google that
[__]
mul mulan's a real person BR Mulan was
100% real person Mulan is a fictional
folk heroine from the northern and
southern Dynasty that means that people
stop believing trying to clown on me
this is host [__] yeah dude he's trying
PVP dude it's a fictional folk heroin
how do they know it's fictional you tell
me legitimate princess in the
traditional sense you tell me a Chinese
lady didn't [__] dress up as a boy to
bat assil is based on a real Chinese
ballad called The Ballad of mov but the
ballad it's based off a song so I think
that means that she ain't real Bas on a
real the song's based off of a fake
story the story is based off of a
inspiration all I'm saying is I think
there's at least one Chinese girl dress
up like a dude in that's [__] Z way
right now she's [__] crazy yeah but
you never seen this picture oh waa you
never seen that no never what you never
seen this picture Jonah AR where her
titties hanging outa pass the phone
around I can see that's the Norton Simon
huh let's see who's Katie
Beltran that name come from she probably
drew it do you look at this and you're
like that kind of looks like Hannah is
that why I don't know maybe
subconsciously I always wanted Jona VAR
and then I got with budaa instead she
not even wearing armor bro none of these
guys kind of are fake she's fake too we
just need to see her I just need to see
I told you her titties are hanging out
and you acting like I'm I'm a crazy ass
you're right crazy ass they're nice
titties I think you're just talking like
a crazy I'm pretty sure it means
something dude leadership is all about
owning your mistakes and I own my
mistakes Mulan was not real and jonov
bar did have a titty right she does have
big titties though baby take the
L give me my phone Nick over here she
does have big titties on a musket okay
so what about Cleopatra if we saw her
did she have snakes on the head can you
put this in the in no I thought that was
Cleo
too no that's Medusa isn't Cleo Patra
known to have maybe some snakes or
something she had the thing on her head
I thought she was um uh what's the right
word when you have both genders on
accidents aite I think she was just a
pharaoh dude no no because their family
there was too much inbreeding and so
there was a birthd something oh def
effect did we say that she was really
pretty did you say that earlier so I
would definitely so I changed my answer
than Cleopatra and I'd say show me the
[__] so I and or penis but what's his
name was it Marcus arelius or uh
Antonius the great or the dude that was
[__] the he was Greek and [__] stoic
dudes cre St homies no herc no she
seduced the [__] out of him I think that
was herculan time Mark Anthony bro
that's also me isn't he the Latin singer
yeah I think it's that's gay oh I'm also
down to meet the inventor of the
microwave like what inspired you to make
opener that's pretty tight what inspired
you that's you could put food in and it
Cooks in like 30 seconds yeah it's a big
deal pretty good when that was probably
not that old that's probably younger
than your grandpa yeah how did he what
gave him the idea he might still be
alive right now the inventor of the
microwave possible maybe what that come
the Industrial Revolution yeah you
should be the richest [__] of
all time yeah that thing's sick maybe he
didn't know how to patent [__] yet you
think his name was like Tom
microwave 1946 first commercial
microwave the Rada range is sold by Ray
fiance restaurants who invested made
they're probably alive whoever made that
[__] been around for a minute man that
popped off that popped off I thought
they just made missiles is huge because
of the M Spencer and Robert Hall two
guys micro or wave in or just Percy
Spencer I don't know we got jip damn how
did they know of this yeah probably a
liot it was probably made to fr humans
at first and then they like we could
probably just make hash browns you're
probably right yeah yeah if it's made by
Ron yeah defense contract yeah defense
contractor or what if the microwave was
like yo this is how they got into the
defense game you know you know true
stepping stone slippery slope got but I
really kind of just want to do
defense I want to meet with King
Nebuchadnezzar oh Nebuchadnezzar is that
the Matrix is that from Babylon
Nebuchadnezzar and the Matrix was a [__]
Babylonian King but even older than that
there's Kings of Sumeria man what are
they known for that's the first
civilized human civilization in the
[__] world dude what do you think
would be good company to hang out with
though cuz I I wouldn't imagine you guys
are going way [__] I was like I want
to have tea with Bruce Lee man CU we'll
speak the same language that's true cuz
I feel like if we kicked it with yeah
they went deep if we kicked it with
gangas con it was just like what are we
going to talk about yo back then the
food was so untainted I bet you if you
had a little tea or coffee that fol
would act like a crackhead oh
yeah Celsius
bro give him some bar Brigade
preout put a hawk on your arm yeah
seriously have gasan teach me some of
his favorite stretches how do you stay
limber while you're yeah how you how do
you stay so athletic like that he' be
like you come here stretch me what about
Masashi is he riding into battle or did
he Outsource his killings after a while
you to ask him I think is era he was
still whooping at he seems like a blood
hungry guy I think at that era you have
to lead bro you can't like Alexander the
Great yeah you got it cuz cuz they'll
beat your ass they [__] kill you
they'll be like you're a [__] cuz even
George Washington LED when did it start
being where all the leaders went in the
back when there's missiles yeah maybe
even yeah maybe like World War I social
media maybe World War I when video
cameras are around yeah cuz it like
Douglas MacArthur [__] standing there
too when did it start being like you
fight the wars from the
back well that's why Eisenhower got in
right cuz there he was like a decorated
hero and most General yeah actually
killed people that's actually a recent
thing where they're like man I'm kind of
scared of those I'm set this one out bro
I'll call in I'll start fighting from
here but that's why in modern day people
love guys like jao you know he's the guy
who on the front line yeah you know the
Tim Kennedy folks have you guys seen
klen the [__] movie it is sick that's
a big [__] Haw it's the name of genas
Khan real oh that's a real name govern
is it out it's old it's it's several
years ago but it was a sick movie he
looks tough yeah he looks tough did you
know World of Warcraft the Orcs are
their characters are built from the
Mongolians is tight oh I would meet
princess
monoke is she real but that's a good
story I see if she's hot yeah what about
Pocahontas what about Sakia dude oh
Pocahontas I wonder if she Pocahontas
was hot she was in the cartoon I jacked
off to that
wow Pocas was off for sure that's the C
want to jack off to Pocahontas you're
just jacking off while you're having tea
with them she's fine dude tell me more
about your life especially if she taking
showers on a waterfall oh yeah dude oh
you know she is she probably smell a
little bit though huh yeah there wasn't
a lot of Dove happening no she probably
smells like [__] natural lavender she
probably smells like Cedar she smells
like lilac smells like cow leather or
some Pine that's not that bad that's
kind hot wearing leather bikinis flowers
it's kind of Primal hot I think they
could treat it that well she might smell
like bison oh yeah oh what if can you
Google what she looks like you don't
eat natural food so then you don't get
Bo oh did uh did Pokemons have Bo you
check that I hey Siri check Snopes I
don't think she did I don't know if she
was real either right she was real was
real yeah there was I thought it's like
the story is based on something B based
off of an image of her they they
recreated it via AI based off of an old
like drawing depicted in like fine as
[__] if AI made her oh nah
busted I knew someone weird what is she
wearing
bro I thought you were going to turn
around Eva Mendes or something I'm like
who the [__] is that hey 16th century
fine is like a three today true maybe
even a two no wonder John Smith moved to
England
that mouth a
[Music]
piece